Good morning.
The title of today's lecture is exploring special subjects on palm pay and walls
and that's exactly what I'm going to do today.
To explore a number of scenes I freeze of figures,
landscape scene,
a portrait portraits on a palm pay in walls,
and also still life painting.
And we're going to look at them both in the context of the architectural style
walls that we've been discussing thus far this term,
especially the second,
third and fourth styles.
But we'll also look at them as interesting in their own right.
We ended last time with a discussion of fourth style Roman wall painting and I
want to show you again what I consider the quintessential fourth style wall.
It's the [inaudible] room in the house of Vte in palm pay,
uh,
and you see it here once again in all it's garish glory.
It's an amazing painting.
We talked about the fact that it is a kind of compendium of all the styles that
went before we described.
For example,
the Sokal,
which is attempt to imitate marble incrustation in paint,
which of course makes reference to the first style of Roman wall painting.
We talked about the fact that the second style elements could be seen in the
substantial columns that are located in the second tier or in the main tier of
the painted wall columns that support a lintel above and a coffered ceiling.
We see those here.
We see them over here as well.
Those again,
elements of the second style.
We talked about the third style features in this particular painting,
the mythological landscape in the center that has a frame,
a black frame around it to make it abundantly clear that this is not a window to
something else but rather meant to look as if it is a flat panel painting
hanging on the wall.
A third style element over here,
another third style element,
the floating a mythological figure in the center.
In this case of a white panel with a,
uh,
with a border that is made up a floral or vegetal motifs.
Again,
elements of the third style with regard to fourth style,
the introduction of architecture once again on either side of the main panel in
the main zone.
Uh,
these are not representations of complete buildings,
but rather as we discussed,
fragments of buildings depicted in illogical space.
And then in the upper most tier,
uh,
we see the architectural cages that we also described as characteristic of the
fourth style.
So all of these elements,
as I said,
a compendium of all of these painting styles all in one place is where Roman
painting up right before the destruction of Mount Vesuvius.
We also have looked,
in fact,
I want to return at the beginning of today's presentation to the villa of the
mysteries in palm pay.
We've looked at it twice already.
We looked at it from the standpoint of it's architectural evolution.
Uh,
we looked at the two phases,
first and second phases of the villa of the mysteries.
And you'll remember the plan.
This is the second phase plan which I showed to you again and you'll recall the
design of the,
of the,
of the villa,
uh,
where you enter at the top,
you enter into the Paris style,
then into the atrium,
then into the tableau denim.
This unusual sequence of rooms that is more in keeping with villa designed
according to Vitruvian,
then to a house design.
And we looked at uh,
a room,
a second style wall painted room,
uh,
called [inaudible] 16,
and I can show you where Kuebix Calum 16 is on this plan.
You see it right over here,
and you'll remember that this was an outstanding example of mature second style
Roman wall painting.
This idea of opening up the wall illusionistic Lee,
remnants of the first stall wall still here.
That wall is dropped down.
Uh,
we do have substantial columns with predict,
projecting and tablatures a coffered ceiling above,
and in this case a lintel and then an RQ weighted lintel.
All of these elements,
a typical of the second style and especially the opening up of the wall to see a
vista that lies beyond,
in this case,
a philosophy around shrine surrounded by a blue sky.
So quintessential second style in [inaudible] 16.
The room that I want to turn to today also in the bill of the mysteries is room
five.
Room five is located over here.
I you see it right to the right of the,
to bleed them and close to the southern side,
close to the great bay window that was added in phase two to provide magnificent
views out over the sea room five.
It's as plain rectangular room or so.
It looks in plan,
fairly large in scale,
not as large as the atrium but fairly large.
And while it's on,
while the plan is on the screen,
I just want to point to the entrance way to the room is very small and France
way here.
It's actually very important in terms of our decoding of these paintings that
we'll find that we find in there,
uh,
that small entrance way.
And then what you see in plan here are actually windows rather than additional
doorways.
And we're going to see that the designer of this particular room,
the painter,
uh,
took the corners,
took the,
the location of the door and also the corners of the room and the,
and the,
and the location of the windows into great consideration when he painted,
uh,
the scenes on this wall.
This is a view of the room five as it looks today.
Uh,
it's often also referred to as the,
uh,
the room with the Diana Dionysiac mystery paintings,
mystery paintings that we'll see feature the god of Wine Dionysus.
You can see from looking at this general view that the paintings are quite
WellPreserved.
We'll see that they cover all four walls of the room except for the witness
space,
except for where the windows are obviously.
Uh,
and you can also see that this is like nothing we've looked at thus far this
semester and that what we have here are a series of very large monumental
figures,
uh,
that seemed to walk around the room in a kind of procession.
And you see those extremely well here
with regard to the,
the,
uh,
style of wall that it is.
I show you another view over here where you can see those same large figures,
uh,
walking,
from the doorway along the side of the left wall.
Uh,
but you can also see the design of the wall as a whole.
And if you look at it carefully,
you will note that the figures are of course placed against these large red
panels between those red panels,
what look not like they're clearly not columns,
but kind of like flat pilasters here,
uh,
that resting on a Sokal down below and then above a meander pattern,
frieze and above that a nother,
a course that represents in paint,
uh,
what looks like very gated marble,
very gated marble.
The implication being,
again,
that would've been very expensive to bring from somewhere else.
So as we look at this,
we think,
well,
it's kind of like a first style wall.
Uh,
but you can see that there,
it's not a relief wall.
It's not built up in Stucco.
It's flat,
uh,
because it was done entirely in paint.
And yet as you look at these very large figures,
you see that they are standing on a ground line that projects into the
spectators space.
Uh,
and that suggests to us that what we are dealing with here,
if we have to categorize this and put it into first,
second,
third or fourth style,
we're going to call it a second style Roman wall painting because it has again,
residual from the first style,
but it's done entirely in paint.
But it has this projecting element at the bottom,
this baseline on which the figures stand and on which the figures process.
So a second style Roman wolf painting with monumental figures and those
monumental figures tell a story.
And it's a very interesting,
very intriguing,
very mysterious,
a story indeed.
And it is from the mystery scenes here by the way,
that the villa of the mysteries are got its name.
This is a view over here,
an excellent view of the small doorway that you need to take a to enter into the
room.
And as you enter into the room and you make a sharp left,
well first of course you entered the room and you get a glimpse of the entire
space.
Uh,
but as you turn to your immediate left,
uh,
you begin with the beginning of the story.
And the artist again has orchestrated this in such a way as to make it look like
this woman who was standing here has actually entered through the doorway of the
room and is now beginning to precess.
Uh,
from that doorway along the side of the room.
If we look at the woman we see that she is wearing a quite heavy,
uh,
heavy garment over here,
but it's a very jaunty representation of this woman because you can,
she,
she has her,
her right hand on her hip and an interest in way.
Uh,
and then most interesting of all is the fact that she wears a veil over her head
and it's a kind of diaphanous veil is I think you can see it's over.
Her head protects her hair.
Uh,
and then it wraps around her.
She wraps it around her chest.
She's holding a one corner of it with her left hand and the rest cascades down
her back.
Uh,
the artist is paid a great deal of attention to that veil because he wants to
identify her for us and to tell us that she is a bride.
Brides were often depicted with voluminous veils like that.
As you see her here,
and she is a bride,
as we're going to find out as we interpret these scenes,
she is a bride,
probably a young Pompei in woman who is about to enter,
who was about to participate in these religious rights that are going to allow
her to kind of like a fraternity or sorority initiation that she's about to
undergo,
let's say a sorority initiation that she's about to undergo because she's about
to go through something that's going to enable her ultimately to enter into a
mystical marriage with the god of wine die in Isis.
So she enters here.
Then she comes upon a two other figures.
There's a seated woman as you can see who holds in her hand or her left hand a
scroll.
Uh,
she has her right hand on the shoulder of a little boy.
Note that the little boy is completely naked and completely oblivious to the
fact that he is naked.
He holds in his hand a scroll,
which he has another scroll,
which she has unfurled and it looks as if he is,
well,
it's no question.
He's very intent on looking at the text on that scroll.
And it looks as if he is reading from the text of that scroll and we interpret
that scroll or we interpret his participation in this scene as probably the fact
that he is reading the liturgy liturgy that has to do with this cult of Dionysus
and with the mystical marriage of women with the God Dionysus.
It's a wonderful depiction of that boy.
And I also show you here,
uh,
the rest of that particular side of the room.
We're going to look at all of the figures in order,
uh,
but I just wanted you to get a sense of the rest of the wall as it unfurls this
left wall as you first come into the room.
Uh,
and I wanted to point out using this image that again,
about how sophisticated this particular artist was because he takes into
consideration,
as I mentioned before,
the corners of the room and they become part of the narrative.
Uh,
as you can see here,
there's an empty space but,
but the story line as we'll see continues across the corner and the figures over
here interact with the figures on the other side of the bend in the wall.
And again,
a very,
very sophisticated and interesting way.
And we'll follow that through.
Before we do though,
I just want to show you a head detail of the seated woman to give you a sense of
the extraordinary talent of this artist whose name unfortunately has not come
down to us.
Uh,
we see this head here and you can see the way in which the artists has captured
the moment,
what this woman is going through,
what she's thinking about.
She seated,
she's listening to the liturgy that's being spoken by this boy.
You can see that the artist is paid a great deal of attention to her eyes,
which are wide open and very nicely painted.
But one gets a sense,
or at least I get the sense is I look at this,
that she,
she is not only wide eyed at what's going on,
but you also have a sense that she's kind of,
it's almost jaded.
I'm just kind of seen it all.
She has a sense of what the moment is a and what is about to occur.
Notice also the way in which her lips are slightly parted,
uh,
and especially the hair the artist is we'll see who was responsible for painting
this.
Uh,
and it may have been more than one artist.
It may have been a designer who worked with obviously others in a workshop.
But whether it's a single individual or several,
it is very clear that this person or this person or persons have a very good
sense of what hair real hair is actually like.
It's the same as I mentioned when we talked about the villa,
the um,
the uh,
uh,
garden scape of Livia.
And I said that that artists had clearly looked at nature and was actually
depicting what he saw and knew about nature.
Here is somebody I believe,
who has really looked at human beings who was really looked at the way in which
hair grows from the scalp because you can see the way in which he has shown that
hair growing from the scalp and he understands that when you part your hair on
this in the middle,
uh,
there may be a certain part of the scalp that you actually see through the hair.
And he's represented that extremely realistically here.
So although we don't know the name of this particular artist,
we can,
uh,
claim his talent here as we look at details such as this one,
the story continues from the boy reading the liturgy to the figure that you see
here.
Uh,
it is a figure,
again of a woman.
She is holding some kind of a dish and she has on that dish probably it's very
hard to identify exactly what's there.
Uh,
but she has probably some items that have something to do with this cult,
with this mystical marriage,
uh,
of these Pompei and women with Dionysus.
She is dressed in,
she has a light colored top and uh,
a purple is a lot of purple in this scene.
A very vividly purple,
a skirt.
As you can see down here.
She is the first woman of the group to where a Laurel wreath over her head as
you can see.
And she and all of them,
by the way,
we're bracelets,
you can see bracelets around her lower arms.
Some of them were these arm bracelets up higher on their arms is we'll also see,
and she's one of the only figures that actually looks out at us,
the spectator.
She really is basically confronting as we linked eyes with her when we look at
this particular painting and the artist is obviously trying to establish fairly
early on a connection between the viewer and what is happening in this scene.
Uh,
the beginning of another scene here with a series of women,
I have a better view of it here where you can see what's happening next.
Here we have three women who are standing at some kind of a table and one of the
women,
the women,
the woman on the right has a picture from which he's pouring some kind of
liquid,
whether it's water or wine or what,
we're not absolutely sure it might well be wine given that this is a,
a the mysteries of Dionysus.
She may be pouring wine,
but whatever it is,
uh,
it has been interpreted as a purification seen,
in which something and we can't see what it is that's underneath this purple
piece of,
of,
of cloth.
Uh,
that,
that the cheap one of the women is,
is holding up and revealing a,
they are purifying that or either an object or a series of objects on this
table.
It's a wonderful depiction of these three women.
One woman holding the edge of the table over here and looking to her compatriot
who is pouring the liquid on this side and a real tour de force.
It's not so easy to depict a figure from the rear and make it work.
But this artist has done so.
A very monumental woman seated on a,
a wonderful thrown here with the,
uh,
with the purple,
Ham as you can see down below.
Uh,
but look at the way he's depicted her garment.
It's tight in some places and molds or body and cascades in others.
She's also wearing a scarf that's tied back behind her head.
And she too.
Where's a Laurel wreath over that scarf?
Uh,
this woman has a Laurel wreath as well,
so they're purifying as part of this,
right?
They are pure,
but women.
Three women are participating and purifying,
uh,
these,
this object or objects here.
This woman has her,
her,
she's,
look,
she's not really looking as you.
Well,
she isn't looking at what she's doing.
As you can see,
she's not actually what doesn't seem to be watching the purification,
but rather is looking at this fellow over here and given what he looks like,
I guess that's not surprising.
Her glance is caught by him.
Now,
who is he?
He is what we call a silo.
Anus,
and the silliness is an older Satre,
a,
t,
y,
r,
who were the seders.
The seders were,
uh,
the,
um,
the compatriots of Pan Pan compatriots of pan.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so a young seder grows up into an old site lameness,
and you see that sideline this here.
And he's a very interesting figure.
Uh,
you can see that he,
he's completely naked and in fact that,
well they're,
they're naked men and naked women in this,
as in this as we'll see.
Uh,
but it's interesting to see that,
uh,
you know,
which ones are and which ones aren't.
He is,
and you can see that this great purple mantle that he had draped around his body
has completely,
or almost completely fallen off.
He is playing a liar as you can see here in probably singing along with his liar
playing.
And not only has his garment fallen off,
but you can see that he is not,
one foot is on the pedestal on which,
uh,
the,
um,
or on a base on which the pedestal that supports the liar is located.
But another leg has slipped off that pedis pedestal.
Why is that?
He's quite tipsy.
Uh,
we know that the silliness,
the PSI lamenesses and the Sanders did a lot of drinking,
very serious drinking.
Uh,
he's clearly a imbibed a and he is not very much in control of himself any
longer.
Uh,
so he's probably pretty oblivious to the fact that his clothing has fallen off
and that he too has slipped off the base as he sings.
So it's not surprising that this woman casts her glance towards the goings on.
Uh,
next to her.
Here are the,
I mentioned that,
uh,
the,
I mentioned the Seder,
the Seders,
and we see two of the young seders right next to that older man.
And the seders again,
uh,
are associated with pan and goats are also associated with pan.
And you can see one of them is feeding the goats here,
these young boys.
And it's true of the man too.
I neglected to mention it all.
Have a sort of pan or animal ears.
Uh,
as you can see very clearly here,
the pointed animal ears and this one is playing a flute.
So one playing a flute,
one playing the one feeding the goats.
Uh,
both of them seated on a kind of rocky area over here.
This figure is of particular interest.
It's a woman clothed with egg white garment that is sleeveless.
She has one of these bracelets on the upper part of her arm.
Uh,
it is clear that she is afraid and she is fleeing from something.
you can see that she holds up her,
uh,
one of her her left hand.
She holds up her left hand as if she is trying to ward something horrific off.
Uh,
and you can see that she is,
but she can't by the way,
while she's holding up her hand toward it off,
you can see that she's absolutely mesmerized by whatever it is that she's
seeing.
Her eyes are staring straight ahead,
wide eyed,
staring straight ahead to look at whatever it is that is at one hand,
fascinating on and on the and the and on the other horrific,
uh,
she is clearly in a rush because you can see that the purple mantle that she
wore a has been caught in the breeze as she,
as she tries to escape the breeze is caught in that and it almost serves the
purpose of a kind of parachute that's about to rescue her from whatever it is
that she has seen.
And that has frightened her.
We are now at the first corner of the room.
So again,
the artist has taken the corner into consideration and created this dramatic
interaction between this woman and whatever it is that she's afraid of on the
other side of the corner.
Uh,
and before I show that to you,
I just wanted to show you a closeup of her face to again,
give you a sense of how talented,
how extraordinarily gifted this artist was in capturing the moment encapturing
the feelings that this woman must have been going through.
Once again,
the very wide eyes fascinated by what she sees.
But seemingly all knowing,
she,
she's seeing something that she doesn't quite expect,
but you get the sense that perhaps she did know all along that she was going to
see something of this nature.
The parted lips once again,
and the expert way in which the artist has shown the way hair naturally grows
out of the scalp of the head.
Again,
achieved a magnificently in this head detail.
Now the object of her fear,
uh,
is what we now see over here.
Here again,
we see the coroner,
the coroner itself and empty red space.
The woman fleeing on this side.
What is she fleeing form?
What is she afraid of?
This horrific mask that is being held by one of the seders.
We see another set of two young seders here and an old silo anus again and one
of the seders holding up this horrible mask.
And that seems to be what has,
uh,
put,
put fear in to the eyes of this particular woman.
With regard to the scene of the Seders,
you can see that the,
uh,
the,
the side lameness and the seders,
the Salinas is seated on some kind of marble block.
As you can see here,
he looks similar to the one that we saw before and older man with those animal
ears,
as you can see,
a,
and he is one of the seders holds the mask a boat.
All of these figures,
by the way,
are,
are you,
you know,
do not have any our semi naked.
You can see that they have bare chests in all cases,
in the mantles only covering the lower parts of their bodies.
And the silliness while looking back toward the woman is holding a large cup,
uh,
from which one of the seders is drinking.
It's a kind of,
I always think of this as a kind of Morrie's cup and you see that the Seder is
whole.
The Salinas is holding it,
the younger Seder is drinking from it.
So again,
there's,
this is a lot to do with,
with drinking and getting drunk.
This,
this mystery,
uh,
and uh,
at least,
at least from the male point of view,
because it actually seems to be the men who were drinking and not the women who
are drinking in this particular instance.
It's a wonderful,
let me also show you a detail of the say of these young Seder drinking out of
the cup and you can see how gifted,
again,
this particular artist is.
I don't think this artist always gets the hands right.
He tries,
uh,
there's sometimes a little bit awkward.
Uh,
but on the other hand,
he really has made an effort to show the way in which hands and fingers grip
something both from the bottom and also from the top.
He's very good with the eyes.
Again,
you get,
it's just wonderful the way he is achieved,
uh,
showing the Seder.
You know,
on one hand,
greedily drinking from the cup,
but at the same time with one eye you can see one eye and that one I is,
you know,
very much on what it is that he's doing.
He's looking at that liquid quite intently as he drinks it.
And I think that's very well achieved here.
And again,
this extraordinary way in which the artist has depicted,
uh,
the hair of this young man as it grows out of his scalp,
particularly talented.
You don't see that very often in Roman painting.
Uh,
the center,
this is,
we're now on the back wall.
We've turned the corner.
It's the back wall,
the wall that you face when you come into the room and look ahead.
Uh,
and we see that the scene that follows,
uh,
the silliness and the seders with the mask is the scene that you see here.
And it is the most important scene in the painting because it is a scene that
represents Dionysus himself,
this man with whom all of these Pompei and women are anxious to be initiated
into his rights and to enter into mystical marriage with him.
Here he is and he is wasted clearly.
I mean,
look at him.
Uh,
you know,
despite the fact that he's about to enter into marriage and all these attractive
young women,
I mean,
he's completely out of it.
He is lying in the lap of Ariadne is mortal lover.
You see her here,
uh,
and look at his eyes.
There's sort of rolled up into the top of his head.
He is,
he is,
he could,
couldn't possibly support him self without Ariadne's help.
Uh,
his arms are,
are,
are outstretched behind him.
In fact,
she has to put her arm around his chest in order to protect him.
And I think it's interesting to see the way in which women are,
are represented as protective beings in these paintings.
The,
the woman earlier on who puts her hand around the boy who's reading from the
liturgy and now Ariadne who rapes her arm around,
uh,
around Dionysus,
Dionysus,
the god of wine.
You can see again that he had a mantle and that's about it on a,
but that is slipping off.
Uh,
and you can also see that he's so drunk that although he's kept one sandal on,
he's lost the other sandal.
You can see his barefoot over here.
You're looking at the bottom of the foot.
That Sandal is going.
And if you look for it,
you can find it.
Here it is.
Uh,
it has fallen off and it is located closer to Ariadne.
Look also at the staff that Dionysus usually carries the fiercest t,
h,
y,
r,
s,
u s the thesis of Dionysus.
Uh,
it's there and it helps to identify him as does the ivy wreath that he wears,
that he typically wears.
Note the yellow ribbon that is tied around the thesis,
but it does,
you know,
one wonders how that theorists,
this is being supported because you can see it's,
I guess it's just leaning slightly against the chair on which Dionysus sits,
but one wonders how it is being,
uh,
supported,
but it crosses his body here and is meant,
again,
as an identifying attribute for the god of wine.
The fact that we see Diane Isis in this state and also on the lap of Ariadne is
interesting,
especially the lap of Ariadne because again,
she was his mortal.
She herself was a mortal,
his mortal lover.
And I think one of the ways of interpreting this as that a scene like this,
seeing that Diane Isis could unite with a mortal woman,
gave hope to the women of Pompei who were hoping to be initiated into this
mystical,
uh,
religion and it,
and to embark on a mystical marriage with Dionysus.
This gave them hope that if another mortal woman was allowed to enter into a
relationship with Diane Isis,
then they too would be able to follow in their,
in,
in our yard and these footsteps.
And so this is a very important message,
I think,
of hope,
uh,
to those women who are hoping to become initiatives,
initiate initiates initiative initiates of this particular,
um,
cult.
The next scene that we see is also a very interesting scene and a very important
one.
It's the one that comes right to the right of the scene of Dionysus and Ariadne.
Uh,
and we see here the discovery of the most important cult object,
uh,
in this scene,
which is the Phallus.
We see a woman kneeling,
uh,
she is,
she,
her arms are wonderfully depicted a as they,
um,
seem to barely touch or whatever it is that lies beneath this,
uh,
purple cloth we see down below a basket.
Uh,
that is certainly the basket in which the Fallis the secret,
uh,
ritual,
the most important but secret ritual item,
uh,
in the Dionysiac religion was kept.
Uh,
and,
uh,
there's been a lot of speculation.
What was behind the purple cloth?
Is it an erect Phallus?
Uh,
very possibly that's exactly what it is.
That would have been kept again in this basket,
but is underneath here,
although the speculation has been so wild that we even have a scholar who has
written an article suggesting that the profile of this particular object,
this particular cloth here is so similar to the profile of Mount Vesuvius.
But what we have here is a reference instead to mount Vesuvius into the fact
that this scene takes place in Palm Bay.
It's a very intriguing idea.
I think it's,
I can't imagine that it's correct.
Uh,
but nonetheless it gives you some sense of the kind of scholarship.
And some of the speculation there has been about what is actually going on here,
but it seems to be,
uh,
the,
the covering in this particular case and possibly about to reveal the secret,
the most important secret item in this cult.
Over here we see another fascinating figure.
We've gotten to another corner and we can see that she straddles the empty red
space in that corner.
A figure of a woman,
uh,
who is winging it.
The only wing had to figure that we see in the scenes,
you can see her large stretch outstretched wings,
uh,
behind her.
She is naked from the waist up.
She's wearing a fantastic skirt.
I love this skirt,
uh,
with uh,
with,
she has a,
with purple around the waist and purple at the Ham.
And then,
uh,
a wonderful,
it flips out,
it's brown and it flips out and it matches these great tall boots,
Brown boots that she also wears.
And she's sort of on her tippy toes as she,
as she herself puts up one of her hands,
perhaps again toward something off.
We don't know what,
but with the other hand what's most important,
she has her hand behind her back and she's about to bring a whip,
which you can stay down on the back of one of the initiates.
And as we look across the corner,
again,
artists masterfully taking the corner into consideration in his design,
visa vi the content and the execution.
Uh,
we see the way in which that whip is about to come down on the back of one of
these initiatives,
who's kneeling and has her a head in the lap of a woman who protects or here is
the scene.
So again,
we see the figure of the wing had figure with the wif.
We see the object of the whipping,
uh,
this initiative here.
Uh,
she is kneeling,
she is in the lab in part of a woman who seems to protect her or try to protect
her.
The woman who was trying to protect her,
her eyes are very wide.
She is staring up at the wing and figure imploringly it seems almost imploring
or please you know enough enough,
please stop.
Uh,
and she is a,
she is very nurturing to the young girl who is undergoing this initiation as she
pats her on the head.
As you can see here.
And incredible view of this woman,
uh,
the way in which the upper part of her body is exposed for the whipping,
the rest of it covered,
and the voluminous purple mantle,
as you can see here,
uh,
also figures to her right.
Uh,
a naked woman who is,
uh,
who,
who is placed in front of interestingly a woman,
a very heavily clothed woman in a dark garment,
which only serves to accentuate the lightness of this woman's flesh.
This,
this sort of contrast or tension between clothed and unclothed also seems to
play a very important part in this particular painting.
But this woman is incredible.
Again,
the artist has,
uh,
has,
has enjoyed trying to represent figures from the rear as well as from the front.
Uh,
and you see a,
he has also shown her on her tippy toes as she is.
She,
she'll,
she has symbols above her head and she's crashing those symbols.
And then she is dancing under tip on her tiptoes down here.
But it's an incredible feat because she also has this gold mantle that is over
her shoulder and between her legs and somehow she's keeping this mantel balanced
as she is dancing and as she is playing her music.
And then there's another one,
another thesis of Dionysus.
It seems to be located that is located between these two women.
And one wonders again,
how in the world that [inaudible] is being held up as this woman is
participating in this,
um,
in this dance and music making over here at the right to get back to this
figure,
I just want to show you a detail because I think in this detail you really get
almost more than anywhere else in this painted freeze,
the extraordinary talent of this particular artist.
I mean,
here,
here the artists gets these hands really,
right?
Uh,
you can see this,
the limp hand of the woman being whipped,
uh,
almost says it all.
It's an incredible detail as does the more nurturing hand of the woman who is
trying to protect her.
Uh,
and I think you can get a sense of what she must be going through.
A by the way in which the artist has represented her face,
he has cast her eye,
her eyes are,
this is one of the only closed dies.
If it may be the only closed die in the scene,
her eye is closed or almost closed.
Uh,
and it is,
it is [inaudible] seems to be sunken in a kind of darkness here.
Uh,
that gives you some sense of the pain that this woman must be going through pain
that she obviously feels however is worth it.
And look also at the way in which the hair has been depicted here you really get
the sense of sweat drenched hair,
uh,
of this woman again,
who's going through what is almost certainly the most difficult moment in her
life,
but one that she hopes,
uh,
is going to,
to be well worth it at the end of the day.
It's an incredible detail.
I think
after that scene there's a window.
And then at the very end of that wall,
we're now on the facing the room on the right wall of the room.
Uh,
there is one last corner and we see here what is represented across that one
last corner.
It is a very young woman seated on a kind of a throne here.
She has an attendance standing next to her and then there's a small wing and
cupid at the left.
And then across the corner we see another cupid standing on a base leaning on a
pedestal.
Wing it again,
he's his,
his head in his on resting on one of his hands.
And he is looking across the corner at what is going on on the other side.
And he looks very,
very admiring.
And in fact,
who is he admiring?
He's admiring another one of these young initiates,
a young woman who seems to be readying herself to become a bride who's getting
ready,
uh,
for her initiation,
she wears a glorious golden garment that is wrapped and wrapped around her waist
is a purple,
purple tie,
a purple ribbon or tie.
As you can see here she is again accompanied by a another woman and attendant
and the two of them together are,
are actually fixing her hair to get her ready again for her mystical marriage.
I have a detail of her to show you in a moment.
And then this wonderful anecdotal detail here where we see the other cupid,
a wing it again holding up a mirror in his hand,
uh,
a rectangular mirror.
And if you look very,
very closely and you can study this detail on your own as well,
if you look very closely,
you can see that there is a reflection of the young woman's face,
uh,
in that mirror.
Uh,
so I,
I lot of a lot of attention being paid to the readying of this woman to be a
bride to enter into the mystical marriage with Diane Isis.
And we see a detail here where we can see her,
see how pretty she is,
see how,
uh,
her,
again,
the artist has shown this extraordinary ability to depict hair as it really is
growing out of her scalp.
You can see the part of her hair,
the scalp,
showing through the way in which the hair grows from that.
And then you can see that not only is she working on arranging it,
but she's getting help from the attendance.
The attendance also has a section of her hair in her hand and the two of them
together are trying to get her ready for her mystical marriage.
Her arm is up.
You can see both of her bracelets and one around her wrist.
And then another bracelet up on the upper part of her arm.
Then we have another window.
And then the last figure,
the last figure that we see,
uh,
is this woman here.
A woman who was seated on a very elaborate thrown,
uh,
she too is veiled.
She has a,
again,
a combination gold and purple garment bracelets.
She's wearing bracelets,
but she is veiled.
Uh,
so again,
the implication is she too is a bride.
She seems very placid.
She seemed somehow a little bit older than some of the other brides.
And what has been speculated and she's very pensive.
You can see she leans one,
she leans her chin on one of her hands.
She seems to be sitting there,
you know,
all right.
At right at the,
and again the,
the doorway of the room.
She seems to be seated there and basically surveying everything that's happening
in front of her.
And because she looks a little bit older because she looks a little bit wiser
because she is looking out at a Pi at the panorama of what's happening in front
of her.
It has been speculated and I think quite convincingly that the woman we see here
is probably the matron of the house,
probably the wife of the man who owned and built the villa of the mysteries in
Rome,
in Nepal pay who was herself an adherent to the cult of Dionysus and has set
aside this secret room in her house,
uh,
for the cult of Dionysus in which she can help initiate other young women,
in to this mystery cult.
Just won a couple of quick words about religion and cults.
During this period,
the Roman religion was the Roman state religion.
Everyone essentially adhered to the Roman state religion,
which was very closely allied with the government of Rome.
Uh,
so church,
a church and state,
very closely allied,
uh,
in,
in Roman times.
But as time went on,
a number of religions that emanated from other parts of the empire,
especially the eastern empire cultivating ionizes,
the cult of the Egyptian goddess,
Isis began to take hold both for men and women.
Women had a particular predilection for the Egyptian Goddess Isis,
and for the DIONYSIAC mystery religions.
And initially because they were not accepted by the state,
the only religion that was considered legitimate was the Roman state religion
and say,
weren't
accepted by the state.
And this included Christianity.
These religions had to be celebrated in or had to be,
the rights had to be done in secret.
And so we see underground,
uh,
rooms,
underground buildings being built for this purpose.
I'll show you one a bit later in the course.
Uh,
but we also see rooms in houses being set aside for these kinds of rights.
And that seems to be what happened.
The woman of the House,
the Metronome,
uh,
the Matera Familia.
So this particular family who lived in the Ville of the mysteries has set aside
room five as the secret chamber,
uh,
in which she can practice the Dionysiac rituals.
And she can also encourage other women in Pompei to partake of those same
rituals.
I just,
just,
I put on your monument list,
you'll see a image of the drawing of all of these scenes that I've now gone
through in order.
And I think it's helpful for you to have that as a reference just to be able to
follow along again,
the narrative and where each of the scenes that we've described comes up.
And then just one last view of the room as a whole.
Uh,
I bring it back because I just wanted to end our discussion of this particular
monument with the point that this is really quite unique in terms of the
paintings that we've seen thus far this semester.
That is to have a painting with such monumental figures that tells the story
that this particular painting does.
Uh,
and I,
it's such a famous set of paintings that Mo that I think because people know it
so well,
they think we'll let that must be a comparable to other things from Roman times.
But this is the only painting that we have like this.
It doesn't mean that there might not have been others,
but I think it probably means that there weren't a lot of others,
that this was truly an exceptional work of art that is preserved in the Ville of
the mysteries at Pompei.
I want to show you in the half an hour that remains a,
uh,
a number of other paintings,
much in much less detail,
uh,
but paintings that also are of special subjects that also belong to second,
third or fourth style walls.
And they're particularly interesting in a variety of ways.
The first of these is also mythological in subject matter.
I'm going to show you the so called Odyssey paintings.
We're moving back to Rome.
These are located in a house on the Escalade hill,
one of Rome's original seven hills in Rome.
Uh,
and while I don't even think I neglected to give you a date for the mystery
paintings,
but those are 60 to 50,
and these paintings are a little bit later,
52 40 BC.
They are also extremely interesting because they seem to represent,
uh,
scenes from the 10th and 11th book of Homer's Odyssey.
And Vitruvian the architectural theorist writing in the age of Augustus.
Truvia tells us that the Greeks were particularly interested in representing the
wanderings of Odysseus in landscapes.
So he tells us it's very important for us to know because it means that the
Greeks painted paintings like this,
uh,
illustrations of a Odysseus's wanderings.
And yet we see one of these paintings in this house,
uh,
on the eschalon hill in Rome between 50 and 40 BC.
The books 10 and 11 focus on Odysseus's coming upon the Lice Oregonians.
I put that name on the monument list for you.
The lice,
draconian,
uh,
and what happens when he meets the lice?
Draconian.
Uh,
and we see one of the scenes here,
we see in fact that several scouts,
uh,
working for Odysseus,
get off their boats on an island.
And they come across this beautiful young woman,
uh,
who is,
has just fetched,
you can see she's holding a picture.
She has just fetched water from a well and she's walking down this mountain and
she comes upon these scouts of Odysseus.
Uh,
and uh,
being a friendly sort,
she says to them,
I'd like to invite you back to my father's house for dinner.
We'll,
her father is a man eating giant,
as are the other lice,
draconian and the scouts fall forward and they come with her to meet her father.
And uh,
the father immediately cooks up one of the three for dinner
and uh,
other various other adventures,
you know,
happen,
uh,
on this island.
But what's particularly interesting for us is the fact that uh,
these,
these scenes,
again our from a well known work of literature but the figures are,
are,
are very small in relation to the landscape.
It's clear that the artist,
whether the,
you know,
originally Greek artists,
we're particularly interested in the landscape and the telling of a narrative
across that landscape.
A landscape that is magnificently rendered as you can see by these artists.
There are a number of scenes still preserved.
Uh,
after that dinner,
by the way,
where,
what are the scouts,
uh,
gets,
um,
gets consumed.
Uh,
after that,
the Leister Goni Ian's,
uh,
decide that they don't want any more of Odysseus and his and his and his crew
and they take boulders as you can see in this scene here.
And they begin to attack the ships of Odysseus,
destroying most of them.
And only the one with Odysseus himself is able to escape.
And He makes his way at that point,
uh,
to the,
to another island to meet up with the and chant and chant truss Searcy.
So we see all of this very carefully described here.
But as we look at these scenes,
I think were particularly struck,
or at least I'm particularly struck and I would imagine you'll share this by the
interest of this artist in depicting the landscape.
We have an artist,
again,
whether it's the original regardless,
but certainly copied here by an artist in Rome.
We see an incredible interest in landscape by someone who is clearly not only
looking at earlier models but looking at landscape itself and is very interested
in depicting all kinds of anecdotal details,
inlets of water as you can see here,
uh,
rocks and the way in which the rock is cast in shadow on one side and his
lighted on the other,
the way in which branch is bend,
both when people pull on them or when they are,
they are a buffeted by the breeze or by the wind as you can see with that tree
at the upper most part of the peak.
So again,
the artists here particularly interested in nature and in the display of nature
and in that way very comparable to what we saw in Olivia's garden scape at the
villa at Prima Porta.
I mentioned already that,
that it is believed that these paintings on the Escalade hill are based on
Hellenistic Greek models that probably were made in about 150 BC.
So a copy.
And in that regard should strike you as very much the same trend as we've seen
so often in the beginning of this semester,
uh,
of the Romans looking back and admiring Greek art and incorporating it,
a kind of Hellenization of Roman art and architecture because of this reverends
and because of this incorporation of earlier Greek,
uh,
scenes and prototypes.
And so we see that here.
And one,
there are three reasons that scholars believe that what we're looking at here is
based very closely on a Greek model.
Uh,
one of those is that passage in Bertrubias that I already mentioned that the
Truvia is tells us that the Greeks were particularly interested in representing
a scenes from the odyssey against the landscape background.
So that certainly tells us that it's likely that these are based on,
uh,
on,
earlier,
uh,
Greek originals.
The second has to do,
you've probably noticed this with the fact that many of the figures in these
paintings are labeled a,
and those labels are,
if you look very closely,
you will see in Greek.
And not only are they in Greek,
but some of the words are misspelled.
So since those words are misspelled,
it has been speculated.
And I think,
again,
quite convincingly that those are who are misspelling them,
don't really know Greek,
uh,
and maybe,
Roman artists who are not familiar with that language or copying it and making
mistakes in the process.
So that also suggests to us that earlier Greek models are being looked at,
absorbed and even copied here,
but most interesting of all for us,
efficient autos of the second style,
uh,
is the fact that very careful,
the archeologists who have looked at these with great care have determined that
the landscape scenes that we've studied,
uh,
our continuous beneath the columns,
that when they copied these,
they copied,
perhaps they had a scroll,
uh,
that they had from somewhere else.
A Greek scroll.
It came from a library that had images on it and they unfurled that scroll and
they copied it here.
They did that first they copied.
So we had a landscape scene and it was only after that landscape scene was
painted that the artists went back and painted the columns on top.
They put these Greek paintings of,
or copies of these Greek paintings of Odysseus's wanderings based on this Greek
prototype of the mid second century BC.
They put it into a Roman context by providing these second,
uh,
style wall,
second style columns or Pilasters pilasters I believe blasters.
Uh,
by creating these second stop pilasters and making this into a vista or panorama
that would have been seen through the window in a sense of a,
a second style painting.
So it's a Roman ization,
uh,
of a,
of an original Greek painting in,
in an extraordinary way that tells us a good deal about how the Romans were
thinking about,
uh,
these Greek prototypes at this particular juncture.
I showed you last time the villa at applaud this,
the call Darian eight.
Uh,
and we looked at the soffit of called Doriam eight,
and we saw a floating mythological figures and we saw women in niches with
shells at the top.
And I pointed out to you at that time,
uh,
that we also have a number of small panel pictures representing,
still lives with fruit and the like.
Uh,
and these get in a sense get lost in the overall scheme of these second,
third and fourth style walls.
But they're very interesting if we look at them in,
in greater detail.
And I want to show you just a two examples today.
This is a a,
it's blown up obviously way beyond the size that it was a,
but it gives you some sense of what these look like in detail.
It's a still life painting that comes from the villa of Julia Félix in Pompei
which dates to around 50 BC.
And we added probably we do believe that it is a detail from a second style
wall.
Uh,
and we look at that detail here and we see that these,
for those of you who enjoy modern art,
for example,
I think you'll agree that this is as tends to be as modern as Roman art gets a,
because we see it has a very contemporary appearance.
I think this particular still life painting,
we see that the artist has shown a striking,
a penchant for,
or sensitivity for composition,
uh,
for light.
The way in which light falls on objects of that are made of different materials,
be it metal or stone.
Uh,
the artists has shown that kind of sensitivity I think here as well as to
composition the way in which a group of objects are composed in relationship to
one another.
If we look at this painting I think will agree it's quite a tour de force.
We see,
uh,
some interesting things which are not that easy to decipher.
A,
we see over here,
for example,
a cloth with fringe that hangs on a nail on the wall.
We see over here also hanging on the wall for dead birds.
We see a plate of oval plate of what seemed to be eggs.
Uh,
we see a picture over here,
which again,
it looks like a metal picture bathed in light on one side with a handle.
And then we see here what it looks like.
Some kind of a beaker with a,
something that may have been used to stir whatever liquid was inside all of this
on the stone pedestal.
And then leaning against that stone pedestal.
We see a one of these clay amp clay,
uh,
vessels,
which seems to have an inscription on that clay vessel.
So what is this a still life painting?
Is it just meant to be a mix of objects that would be found in the kitchen of a
house or is it something more than that?
Do these have meanings beyond that?
Is there some religious symbolism here?
For example,
this is not easy to decipher and no one really has done that satisfactorily up
to this point,
but it's something that one would want to keep in mind as one thinks about the
meaning of the still life paintings.
And keep in mind,
again,
if you think back to a room like the flexion room,
there are a number of these small panel paintings in the ECC on room.
When you look at the room as a whole,
these are not easy to see.
They're,
they're so small that they're lost in the overall scheme.
So you'd really have to go up very close,
uh,
to these if you could even reach them.
If they're way up in the top,
it would be difficult.
But if they're down below,
go up close,
look at them and try to figure out for yourself exactly what is going on here.
Another one,
uh,
from,
in this case from Herculaneum,
which is not not so ingeniously called a still life painting with peaches and
glass jar,
but that's very descriptive.
That's exactly what it depicts,
which is later in data around 62 to 79 and probably it was a panel in either a
third or a fourth style,
a Roman Roman painting,
more Roman painted wall.
Uh,
we see two tiers here.
We indeed do see,
uh,
peaches and the artist again has really looked at peaches to depict this,
shows the peaches on the vine with the leaves as you can see here and wants to
make sure that we know what a peach looks like inside as well.
So has cut a section off one of these and shows the pit inside just to make sure
that we get a full sense of,
of how peaches grow,
uh,
and uh,
of what happens when you,
when you open a peach and then down here below a glass vase.
And you can see that the artist has filled that boss halfway with water so that
he can explore the effects of light on that water and the reflection of that
water on the glass vase itself.
So clearly,
again,
artists that there,
there,
there may be other reasons that a juxtapose these particular items,
these reasons that may be beyond our comprehension,
uh,
today.
But while they may do that for ritual or other reasons,
they also are clearly very concerned with just exploring composition,
light,
uh,
and so on and so forth.
As I said before,
which is a very,
which is a very modern thing to do.
We also see among the paintings that I've called special subjects today,
a genre scenes,
scenes that represent daily life in palm pay or Herculaneum.
I'll show you just one of those here.
It is a painting of [inaudible].
We usually call it a painting of a magistrate distributing free bread.
And it comes from house seven,
three 30 in Pompei,
a wall painting from seven three 30 and Pompei dates to around d 70.
And what's depicted here,
whether the magistrate is distributing free bread or it's bread being sold,
we're not absolutely sure,
but what you can see here is piles and piles of round breads that are being
distributed to those who stand in front of the,
uh,
bread stand.
And I can show you a detail also of the same,
where you can get a better sense of the shape of the breads.
You remember the petrified,
petrified bread,
uh,
that we looked at from Pompei and the,
um,
the division into shapes that make it resemble a pizza.
Uh,
the same kinds of breads can be seen here in,
it's those,
that bread that is being distributed to these people down below.
While this,
while this painting comes from a house,
uh,
there,
you know,
and it may have been,
may have just referred to the particular profession of someone who lived in that
house,
but paintings like this we believe,
and it may or may not have been the case with this one,
could also have,
we're were also used as shop signs to advertise,
uh,
what was being sold in one of those to bear.
And I,
uh,
that opened off off that often opened off houses in places like palm pay and
Herculaneum.
And that may have been the case here as well.
Just a few words about what we might call history painting.
Uh,
among the Romans.
This is a fascinating and very famous painting of the amphitheater at palm pay.
You see it on the lefthand side of the screen that comes from house one,
three 23 in palm pay and dates to between 59 and 70 ady.
And it purports not only to represent,
uh,
the Pompei amphitheater,
which I remind you of here.
And you'll recall the very distinctive staircase of the amphitheater pump pay.
And you can see how carefully that is rendered here by the artist to make sure
that we know this is indeed the amphitheater at Pompei.
It purports to represent a very famous historical event,
at least for it,
at least in terms of local history.
And that is a brawl that broke between the palm pains and a,
uh,
another group of individuals who lived in the area called the nutrients and u c
e r I a,
n s upon pains and the nutrients,
a brawl broke out between them.
You can see that brawl being represented in the oval arena.
There,
the brawl was so serious that the local magistrates decided to punish both the
palm pains and the nutrients and they did something quite extraordinary.
And that is that they decided to close down the amphitheater in palm pay for 10
years.
Count them.
I mean,
can you imagine,
uh,
the city of palm pay without an amphitheater for 10 years.
That was a very brutal,
uh,
punishment,
but it seems to have happened,
uh,
and it is memorialize that very event is memorialized in this painting,
in this house at Pompei.
This painting is also very valuable.
I think I've mentioned this to you before is also very valuable,
not only for showing us the shape of the,
uh,
of the,
amphitheater,
which of course is,
you know,
still survives the oval shape and the seating,
but for an a,
for a detail that doesn't still survive.
And that is the awning I mentioned to you that an amphitheater design,
uh,
they put poles at the very upper most part of the amphitheater and they would,
were able to put an awning on those poles to protect people in inclement
weather.
And we see the representation or only preserved representation in paint a of one
of these awnings.
Uh,
so again is very valuable in terms of helping us understand a amphitheater
design.
The last two paintings I want to show you today are both portrait paintings.
And you have to think of these portrait paintings like the mythological panel
pictures as paintings that were inserted into walls,
uh,
inserted into a,
you probably mostly third and fourth style Roman walls.
And when all of when those treasure hunters hit Pompeii and Herculaneum,
these were the ones they went to first.
They cut a fair number of these out of their original context and,
and made off with them.
But some of them,
fortunately you have found their way into,
especially into the Naples archeological museum.
This is the first one that I want to show you an absolutely fetching a portrait
of a young woman from Pompei.
Uh,
that dates to around the middle of the first century,
a d that is 45 to 50 a d.
Uh,
and we see it here and it's a,
it's a,
it's an incredible,
uh,
painted portrait by clearly once again,
a very talented artist who's done an extraordinary job of capturing this woman.
It's a very,
very,
uh,
appealing portrait.
We see her.
She's quite attractive young woman with wide,
uh,
sort of Hazel colored eyes,
a sharp straight brows,
um,
straight nose of sort of a cupid cupid's lips.
As you see down below,
the hair is magnificently rendered.
You can see that she has,
uh,
a bevy of corkscrew curls.
Those,
the front toward the front of her face are highlighted and match very well.
The color of her eyes that she wears gold hoop earrings that also mimic the curl
accuse of her locks.
And then you can see also that she wears something that appears to have been
fashionable to wear among Roman and Pompei and women.
And that is a gold hairnet at the very apex,
which adds a shine and,
and,
and a glimmer to her port to the hair.
Uh,
but also you can see the hair,
but beneath it threw that down below.
You can see she wears a green garment and a,
a,
a sort of purple or brownish mantle over her shoulder and she holds a stylist to
her lips and she has in her other hand,
uh,
a,
um,
uh,
as you can see a tablet in front of her and she is,
it is clear as she puts that stylist to her lip,
she has deepened thought,
very pensive,
uh,
figuring out what it is that she's going to write on her wax tablet because
these were wax and they would write into the wax tablets because she is caught
in this moment of a deep thought.
A number of scholars have suggested that she must represent the Greek Poetess
Sappho.
Uh,
which is why I put that painted portrait of Sappho on your monument list.
But you can see I've put Safo in quote marks.
I think this is almost certainly not Sappho.
Uh,
it is probably a palm pay in woman and she may not be thinking about the poetry
that she's about to write,
but perhaps the shopping list,
uh,
that she's putting together before she makes her way down to the central market
of the city of palm pay or sends her slave to go down to the central market of
the city of palm pay.
But it may also be that she was literate,
uh,
and that she wants to underscore the fact that she was literate.
It may also be that this was just a set way of representing women in portraiture
and palm pay because this is not the only portrait we have of a woman with her
stylist to her lips and her tablets in our hands.
Here's a,
another portrait that we have also from palm pay with a woman represented in
exactly the same way.
This portrait is from house seven to 60 and dates to around 62 to 79.
A d the portrait of a woman and presumably her husband by her side.
She again has the stylist to her lip.
She has the tablet down below.
You can see that he holds a scroll,
which has a,
um,
a red place marker,
uh,
up above a.
So this portrait of the two of them may either a allude to the fact that they
are both literate,
that they can both read and write.
It's also possible that the,
uh,
that the scroll that he holds may indicate that he's a magistrate or lastly,
and one of the more popular solutions is that this May,
he may be holding the marriage certificate,
the marriage between the two.
Uh,
the portraits are very interesting.
You can see that she isn't quite as gorgeous as her other counterpart.
Um,
her hair is not a range in those wonderful,
uh,
golden locks but are kind of frizzy over her forehead and down her neck.
As you can see here,
her ears stick out to you as a unit brow.
Uh,
but she's,
she's,
she's more than happy to be represented as she was preserved for posterity as
she was a along with her husband over here.
And if you look at the portrait,
you will see again that it has a black frame around it.
And then a Maroon frame,
which tells us again that this was inserted into a wall,
a third or fourth style wall.
Uh,
just like the mythological paintings were inserted into those walls,
uh,
as a,
as a painting that was located in the center of that wall.
And in this case emphasized,
uh,
the,
the owners of this particular house,
uh,
and their,
their undying love for each other.
Their relationship honors their marriage,
uh,
and served as a kind of counterpart to a portrait of the loving couple that one
might put on a mantle piece or on a piano in one's house today.
So you have to think of it as quite comparable to that.
Again,
when you wander through Pompei,
you don't see many of these portraits and C2 in large part because they were so
popular with treasure hunters.
But fortunately,
we do have a few preserved,
uh,
in,
from both Pompei and Herculaneum.
And those can be seen in museums like Naples today.
Thank you.